Now suppose the starting point is a sequential
program. How can we exploit the cluster? We
have multiple processors, how do we exploit the
cluster if the starting point is a sequential
program? One possibility is to do what is
called automatic parallelization. That is, instead of writing
an explicitly parallel program, we write a sequential
program. And let somebody else do the heavy lifting
in terms of identifying opportunities for parallelism that
exist in the program and map it to
the underlying cluster. And this is what is
called an implicitly parallel program. There are opportunities for
parallelism, but the program itself is not written
as a parallel program. And, now it is
the onus of the tool, in this case
an automatic parallelizing compiler, to look at the sequential
program and identify opportunities for parallelism
and exploit that by using the resources
that are available in the cluster. So
high-performance FORTRAN is an example of a
programming language that does automatic parallelization,
but it is user-assisted parallelization in the
sense that the user who is writing
the sequential program is using directives for
distribution of data and computation. And those
directives are then used by this parallelizing
compiler to say, oh, these are opportunities
for mapping these computations onto the resources of
a cluster. So it puts it on different nodes on the cluster and that
way, it exploits the parallelism that is
there in the hardware, starting from the sequential
program and doing the heavy lifting in
terms of converting the sequential program to a
parallel program to extract performance for this
application. This kind of automatic parallelization, or implicitly
parallel programming, works really well for certain
classes of program called data parallel programs. In
such programs, for the most part, the data accesses are fairly static, and it is
determinable at compile time. So in other words, there is limited potential for
exploiting the available parallelism in the cluster
if we resort to implicitly parallel programming.